[Música]
este 25 de Mayo es el Día de África
Nosotros hemos querido hacer el énfasis
en France 24 abordando la cuestión del
tratamiento mediático de las noticias
del continente planteando para usted y
para también nuestros periodistas en
sala de redacción la siguiente pregunta
está la cobertura mediática de África
a la suficiente altura de lo que ocurre
en esta región del mundo y para hablar
de este tema me acompaña la experta amal
Ben notman presentadora de France 24 y
de nuestro programa África siete días
para usted Buenos días Ángela
absolutamente entonces para intentar
analizar este tema de la cobertura de
África me fijé en dos noticias recientes
que en la opinión de muchos observadores
demuestran la escasa cobertura que se le
dedica al continente africano la primera
se refiere a un informe de la ONU sobre
la masacre de mura un pueblo del centro
de Mali el documento fue publicado el 12
de mayo y las Naciones Unidas
confirmaron que el ejército maliense
junto con mercenarios extranjeros a los
que muchos testigos acusan de ser
paramilitares del grupo ruso Wagner
asesinaron a nada más y nada menos que a
500 civiles durante una incursión que
duró cinco días entonces Ángela cinco
días de masacre en lo que también se
acabó con la vida de mujeres y de niños
y entonces analizando la cobertura esta
fue una noticia muy poco difundida por
los medios de comunicación incluso por
las 24 Porque si bien lo tuvimos en
nuestros titulares nos hace falta mucha
más pedagogía para para abordar estos
temas absolutamente Sí fue mencionada
fue mencionada pero el caso no recibió
el cubrimiento que merecía la mayoría de
los medios de comunicación incluso
France 24 lo abordaron de forma somera
sin sin entrar en detalles ni darle al
espectador o al lector al contexto
necesario para comprender la gravedad de
lo que había ocurrido y añadiría que hay
muchas masacres como la de mora en el
particular en la región del zagel que de
las que apenas oímos hablar
es importante aquí poner todo en
contexto como usted dice y si nos
atrevemos a compararlo con coberturas
mediáticas de otros crímenes similares
de otras masacres ocurridas en lugares
distintos del continente africano o del
mundo nos damos cuenta que el
tratamiento de medios no es el mismo y
por supuesto que no es nuestro ánimo
poner una masacre por encima de la otra
porque eso tampoco sería responsable
absolutamente O sea no es comparar pero
las comparaciones pueden dar también una
una visión de la manera con la que
cubrimos algunas regiones En comparación
con las otras en el caso de la masacre
de bucha en Ucrania los periódicos y los
canales de información desplegaron
importantes medios para informar de lo
que había sucedido y no se limitarán no
se limitaron perdón a mencionar la
masacre sino que lo que le dieron
profundidad en su tratamiento y sobre
todo hubo un seguimiento la
mediatización de la masacre se hizo
durante semanas
y otro ejemplo Angela son las recientes
inundaciones en el este de la República
democrática del Congo que mataron a más
de 400 personas de nuevo la cobertura
mediática no estuvo a la altura de la
catástrofe Y si hacemos la comparación
por ejemplo con las inundaciones que
asolaron el estado de Kentucky en
Estados Unidos el pasado mes de agosto o
más recientemente las inundaciones en el
norte de Italia podemos ver que la
cobertura es desproporcionada vemos
entonces efectivamente que los medios de
comunicación tanto escritos como
audiovisuales pues no hablan mucho de
África en contraste con otras zonas
geográficas y las consecuencias de esto
usted las ha mencionado ya en diferentes
espacios y quisiera que aquí por favor
la repitiera para nuestros televidentes
de la mañana sí básicamente las
consecuencias son en primer lugar la
marginación total del continente y
también también una visión distorsionada
de lo que de lo que ocurre en en él
viene pues Mire yo lo que quisiera es
que pudiéramos ampliar más este tema mal
y para ello nos acompaña también se
conecta con France veinticuatro viviano
quien es el politóloga especialista
también en relaciones Europa África y
además experta en el sahel y Mali vivían
Muchas gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros y qué bueno tener este análisis
de su parte si gusta comenzar con las
preguntas absolutamente bienvenida
Vivian Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros Entonces yo quisiera Vivian
volver a la masacre de mora Cómo se
puede explicar que no hay que los medios
de comunicación no hayan dado más
espacio mediático a este a esta tragedia
primero Muchísimas gracias por invitarme
Hoy es un día muy importante es el Día
de África entonces creo que es muy
pertinente que abordemos la marginación
que ocurre hacia el continente la
masacre de mura no es la única masacre
que ha quedado completamente o muy
invisibilizada en los medios de
comunicación sino que verdaderamente
todos los todos los avances todas las
cuestiones que ocurren en el Continente
tienen un espacio mediático muy
ínfimo no Y eso no ocurre solamente en
las cuestiones negativas sino también en
las positivas es decir si bien para
otras regiones del mundo también
escuchamos o podemos acceder fácilmente
a información en los desarrollos y el
progreso tecnológico social cultural y
etcétera Esto no se ve en el continente
africano no y existen una una gran
variedad de razones por las que esto
ocurre primero la digamos la
financiación que reciben los medios de
comunicación para cubrir África es decir
es una región que tiene muy poca
financiación y hay una precarización
también de de los periodistas que lo
tienen que hacer muchas veces como
freelance o como de una manera como muy
Autónoma y con muy pocos recursos
también se da la falta de interés por
parte de la sociedad de los avances y
las cuestiones que ocurren en África
porque realmente no es solamente que no
estén en los medios de comunicación es
que tampoco lo estudiamos en el colegio
es que tampoco forma parte de nuestra
vida cotidiana tenemos esa imagen
prefijada de África como un espacio
pasivo en decadencia donde solamente hay
pobreza y Guerra y no es atractivo y no
importa verdaderamente a la población
que cree que lo que ocurre es
exactamente siempre lo mismo no Entonces
yo diría que estos son algunas de los de
las razones más importantes por las
cuales no hay coberturas que no hay
interés y como no hay interés no se
destinan fondos Tampoco porque uno habla
del colegio solamente mencionan barcos y
barcos de miles de personas esclavizadas
que llegaron desde el continente
africano ahora quisiera preguntarle
usted diría que África sufre en efecto
como nos está explicando una
discriminación de los medios de
comunicación y le voy a poner un ejemplo
con el tema por ejemplo de República
democrática del Congo y las inundaciones
es difícil a veces para las cadenas de
noticias incluso hacer el cubrimiento
porque las agencias internacionales
tardan más días en enviar las las
imágenes en enviar la información en
conocerse una fuente fidedigna de lo que
realmente está pasando pero esto tiene
que ver mucho también con el presupuesto
que se dedica a poner periodistas en
esos terrenos
Efectivamente es o sea esto O sea como
como usted perfectamente dice la
cobertura que hay sobre África es muy
baja Pero también es que el nivel de
especialización que hay hacia África es
baja es decir los sexy Por decirlo de
alguna manera es cubrir china es cubrir
Estados Unidos es cubrir a las potencias
globales o sea lo que vemos con África
no ocurre solamente con África también
por ejemplo en toda la región donde
están kazajastán y todos estos pequeños
países asiáticos también ocurre es decir
todo aquello que salga fuera de de las
potencias globales y algunos otros
países estratégicos siempre queda fuera
no Entonces en este sentido también hay
una necesidad de la construcción de de
una industria periodística africana
fuerte no que sea esta misma industria
la que sea capaz de mandar a los medios
de comunicación de todo el mundo las
cosas que van ocurriendo no
y y yo diría que que como para concluir
que sí que hay una necesidad de que los
medios de comunicación empiecen a
prestar mucha más atención al continente
pero vuelvo a referirme a la cuestión de
la educación mientras en los currículos
educativos de la primaria de infantil de
la universidad África tampoco tenga
relevancia es decir África no tenga
relevancia en el espacio académico ni en
el espacio político Por decirlo de
alguna manera y nos vaya bien que sea
esta este continente pobre al que
tenemos que ayudar y que no tiene ningún
tipo de agencia o como mínimo eso es lo
que parece que
absolutamente absolutamente
Una última pregunta para usted como
especialista en África
que Qué temas o qué cobertura le
gustaría ver más en los medios de
comunicación internacionales
hoy Esta es una pregunta fantástica
Muchas gracias a mí me gustaría ver el
rol que los jóvenes están teniendo en el
desarrollo africano Me gustaría ver
todos los proyectos de emprendimiento y
de innovación que se están llevando a lo
largo y ancho del continente Me gustaría
ver hablar sobre la entrada de mujeres y
jóvenes en la política me gustaría
también Escuchar hablar sobre el
desarrollo científico en el continente
cómo se están identificando y abordando
diferentes enfermedades me gustaría
también Escuchar hablar sobre las
estrategias diplomáticas que África está
llevando a cabo a nivel internacional
para ganar poder sobre el avance de la
agenda 2063 yo creo que que hay
tantísimas cosas que podemos
visibilizar también a nivel cultural la
industria cinematográfica
etcétera no O sea creo que hay muchas
cosas que podemos abordar